now let's jump back to recursion so if I
would like to compute multiple bounces
I'll need to handle this somehow and we
have talked about this briefly if I
intersect the first object I need to
reflect the Ray off of this object in
some way and after the shading is done
if your specular and Beyond shading then
we can trace the light further and this
tracing step can be both reflection and
refraction you remember feni's law and
Snell's law we are going to put them in
and use in a second but what I need to
tell you is something super weird but
you won't feel why this is weird so in a
ray tracer recursive ray-tracing are not
global illumination the indirect
illumination is that very low spot next
actually in the Ray tracer if you
encounter the mirror an ideal specular
reflector you will bounce the way back
in the ideal reflection direction so
exactly what you would see in the mirror
it's 45 degrees it is 45 degrees back
and you do the same with diffuse
surfaces as well so you continued array
in ideal reflection direction and now
this sounds reasonably okay but when you
will study global illumination and how
the whole thing is done how real men
compute the rendering equation and
images you will see that this is a super
super huge simplification I would
remember the faces of students when they
think back when they know all about
global illumination of you talk about
simple recursive ray tracing and I asked
them how is this reflective and there's
silence because they will know that in
global illumination is going to be so
natural that the diffuse surface means
that it will reflect light in every
direction with the very same probability
so the perfect reflection direction has
the same probability as coming back
the same direction where it entered the
surface they all have the same
probability all directions and then
suddenly a ray tracer says that even a
diffuse object I'm going to tweet has a
mirror so this is going to be super
weird and please remember that I say
this later on if you take a look at ray
tracers after global illumination now
how does an equation book I hit
something I reflect array so the light
rays are always the perfect reflection
direction and I'm going to restart the
whole process I'm going to start to
trace a new ray that starts on the
object remember this is when you get the
self intersection T equals zero I
increment this Maps maximum very bad
value to show how many bounces I have
computed so far and let's start again so
I start a new way I imagine that this
object is now the camera and this is
whether a is starting from is there a
question or okay so we got everything
how does it look like in terms of
mathematics this is the illumination
equation without recursion that now I
need to add one more term let's quickly
a cactus the first term is the ambient
term this is too warm and up the
completely black shadows this is
basically a bunch of hacks but it looks
good so we are going to be okay with
this for now
then we scare the amount of incoming
light with the material properties so
the diffuse and specular shading model
these are weighted by K B and K s this
these are values that tell you how to
use or how specular this object is and
not only how specular it is what color
is positives or what powers does it
reflect so what is the color of the
object what is the diffuse and specular
albedo of the object using so many terms
not because I'm inconsistent but because
people use all of these terms and
therefore you should be familiar with
this and there is some weird stuff that
I now added and this is
recursion part so katie is the final
transmission coefficient this is the
probability of refraction because you
remember that I hit this air glass
interface from different directions and
if I hit them from different directions
that the probability of reflection and
refraction is different so depending on
the incoming direction you have seen
this laser is stronger in one direction
than the other and we have to account
for this with these transmission
coefficients and the IP is the intensity
that is coming from that direction the
kr and IR or the other way around
so if there is reflection not refraction
then I am going to go in that direction
and I'm going to scale this with the
intensity of the incoming light from the
reflection direction a quick example
where if I have a glass that's being so
some kind of glass that that looks
almost entirely P then this final
transmission coefficient is going to
describe the color that's bluish
therefore all the energy that comes
through this ball is going to be colored
to blue and the phenol reflection
coefficient can be whatever so we are
now interested in the transmission so
this is how I can define materials like
that this is the recursion part and for
this I need to start perhaps multiple
rays so if I hit this object and I say
that hey this is a missing object dress
what do I do because there is a
probability positive probably - usually
for reflection or refraction do I start
to recursions to do rays
what do I do exactly in the assignment
that I'm going to talk about you will
see a piece of code that does something
and then you will see the effect of
something I'm not going to spoil
anything and just a quick introduction
to helpers notation this is
important because if you know this kind
of notation then you will be able to
discuss what kind of ray tracing
algorithm can render web kind of light
paths so as a status quo all light paths
go between light sources in the eye if
it doesn't hit if it doesn't hit the
lens of the camera it's not going to be
recorded in the image so every light
source is every light path is going to
be written as L something-something E or
as this is bi-directional you can
imagine the other way around so you can
say e something something that the
denotes whence one diffused into
reflection during the way s is one
specular into reflection during the way
and the asterisk means any amount of
diffuse bounces perhaps even zero so LD
e means that either I hit that di from
the light immediately all there is one
diffused bounce or maybe an arbitrary
number of the few sponsors this is what
the asterisk tells you and we can also
denote a choice the choice means that
there is only one either specular or one
day few spots and with this small that
powerful notation we can discuss all the
algorithms there are to render
photorealistic quality images so for now
some of this will be intuitive some of
this will be not so intuitive because we
don't know global illumination yet but
first ray casting means that we hit at
most one diffuse object that's all it
can render no recursion nothing I just
hit one diffuse object I do the diffuse
shading and do by radiosity can compute
something like indirect illumination
because multiple diffuse balances are
possible so remember the example the
line comes in to the classroom from you
know he's survival and that is the over
and therefore the aura is not going to
be perfectly black this is called
indirect illumination
radiosity scarf covered we clarify
tracing what
doing with this phenyl transmission and
reflection thing we know that what we
can do is indirect illumination
definitely not because we treat a
diffuse object also as a mirror we just
use a different shading function for it
so we don't choice rays all along
the hemisphere of the object because it
collects light from every direction this
is why it doesn't change your family's
my head this is why the sight of it
doesn't change but we cannot account for
that this would be a huge dimensional
integration problem that we're going to
solve in the rendering equation so at
most one diffuse bounds but you may have
as many specular bounces as well as you
need so this is why recursive ray tracer
usually show you mirrors and glass balls
and reflective things like that because
it is capable of rendering it but not so
much more and global illumination that's
the full package an arbitrary number of
diffuse or specular bounces this can
also be glossy whatever kind of
complicated material model you have here
this D s can be anything and in any
amount now let's take a look at an
example with the Hagbard notation so
here we have live paths and they start
out from the light source so on the
right I have something like LD de that's
exactly what I have been talking about
so I start from the light source
I hit a diffuse wall I hit the diffuse
ground and then I hit the camera
afterwards so that's led let's take a
look at for instance an SSD so I start
from the light source I hit the glass
ball from the outside this left glass
ball and then I go inside the boulders
going to be refraction at least let's
imagine that there's going to be R
refraction and then I hit it on the
other side as well and they come out so
this is two specular bounces lssd so we
can denote light paths and understand
algorithms can render what exactly so
here if we imagine that this is a ray
tracer this is an image with a ray
tracer the question is what did they do
and this is a rather low quality image
but let's it seems to me that the
shadows are not completely black
therefore in their training knowledge
they definitely use them
what kind of turn raise your hand if you
know the answer so normally this would
be completely black because I shoot the
shadow ray towards the light source and
it is going to be eluted
by the table so intensity zero imagine
that like all possible shadow rays are
blocked but this is still not completely
black because I'm having a term to it in
order to warm up and make the image a
bit more realistic so this would be
which term this would be the ambient
term excellent